tonight on the new reality
you can't get blood from a stone i won't
be able to pay the rent battered
financially by the coronavirus pandemic
now on the brink of losing their homes
i'm feeling
the fear of homelessness i observed
tenants being
evicted in as little as 60
90 seconds homelessness has always been
killing people
but when you have a pandemic at play it
has never been
this stark they move four meters a
second
it takes your breath away it's
mesmerizing a symphonic ballet of
technology
canadian companies they know they have
to innovate they know they have to
automate
will this result in fewer jobs it is
absolutely the opposite it is a job
creation
hello and welcome to the new reality i'm
donna friesen
since the start of the pandemic we've
heard it over and over again
we're all in this together stay home
stay safe
for millions of canadians living
paycheck to paycheck though that is not
an option
canada has long had an affordable
housing problem and experts say among
all the other issues covet 19 has
created there is now a full-blown
eviction crisis as well many people are
now faced with a terrible choice
go hungry or risk losing their homes and
for some the only remaining option
is to get organized and fight back
here's farah nasser
not now
battered financially by the coronavirus
pandemic
now on the brink of losing their homes
they've had
enough tenants have been organizing and
protesting evictions
since last summer as the virus surges
again
people like zineth jahan are broke
and wondering how they'll survive i'm
feeling
the fear of homelessness it wasn't
always this way
zineth moved to canada from bangladesh
four years ago to join her husband
and build a better future for their
daughters then
her husband was diagnosed with an
aggressive cancer
it was november 2019 we got admitted in
the hospital
more than two months he fight and then
2020 january he passed away
but there was no time to mourn zenith
took more hours at her fast food job to
cover the rent and support her daughters
and then barely a month after losing her
husband
the pandemic hit
i lost my husband lost the major part of
income
lost my job by april even with canada's
emergency response benefit
bills were piling up and she could no
longer afford
the fifteen hundred dollar rent on her
one bedroom apartment
some people will say that well don't you
have some money set aside right i had
saved
some but i have run out you know during
my when my husband was in the hospital
with no income how much money do you owe
right now
8 thousand eight thousand yeah zenette
said she had only missed one month's
rent
when she got an eviction notice in may
and
struggled a lot after that zenith became
a leader of a group of tenants pushing
back against evictions that's how she
met
carly tisdale i've never had trouble
paying the rent before
i've never had to call my landlord and
ask for a solution when i'm worried that
i'm not going to be
able to pay the rent next month i've
never gotten involved in my community
this way
carly is an actress and model she says
she told her landlord she wouldn't be
paying rent in april
the following month she also got an
eviction notice
you can't get blood from a stone i'm
telling you i won't be able to pay the
rent
and we were told work it out with your
landlord you can negotiate nobody's
going to get
tossed out on the street in this
pandemic if you have a choice between
putting food on your table
or paying rent you're putting food on
your on your table people will not be
evicted
despite that promise it's estimated that
close to a hundred thousand families in
ontario
are struggling to pay their landlords
during the pandemic
the total unpaid bill is pegged at
nearly 80 million dollars
every month housing advocates say tens
of thousands of renters are facing the
threat
of eviction so residents of several
apartment buildings in the same east
toronto neighborhood
formed tenants unions they hold hallway
meetings to discuss strategy
and ask their landlords to negotiate
with them as a group
it's just something that had to happen
because here
in my community it just feels like at
this point we're the only people that we
can rely on
so do tenants have any other recourse
during an
unprecedented pandemic to keep their
homes most provinces had a moratorium on
evictions during the first wave but by
the end of summer
those bans were lifted and in ontario
the landlord and tenant board's eviction
hearings had moved online
at warp speed this whole process of
online evictions was set up
specifically to facilitate the massive
evictions
of tenants during covet cole weber is an
outreach worker at parkdale community
legal services in toronto
he says there were 7 000 hearings in
ontario
in november alone a 20 increase from the
year earlier
you had all kinds of technical
difficulties
and glitches where people weren't able
to
call in or who were thrown off the call
yet the hearing went on without them and
they were ordered
evicted i observed tenants being evicted
in as little as 60 90 seconds
i fractured my back that's what happened
global news obtained a transcript if a
hearing of a tenant who is evicted
because she fell behind on rent during
the pandemic
and was physically unable to return to
work i'm 56 years old and this is not
where i want to be
and honestly i want to get up and down
the stairs so i can be active
and get my legs moving and being
proactive but i can't do that
tell me about the rent
and some communities are
disproportionately struggling during the
pandemic
those in low paying jobs with no
security or sick pay
in may a record 2.6 million canadians
were unemployed or
13.7 percent by july the overall
unemployment rate had dropped to 9.3
percent
but in racialized communities it was
nearly double that figure
you know we've heard this entire
pandemic we're all in this together
do you feel like we're all in this
together i know we are not all
together in this crisis regions are
becoming rich
poorer becoming more poor as the virus
slowed over the summer
and economic conditions began to improve
many tenants in this area began paying
rent again in october
plus they made extra payments toward
what they owe
in return they requested a rent
reduction and partial forgiveness of
unpaid rent
zinet's landlord rejected the group's
requests and her eviction notice
is still pending pinedale properties
claims they haven't evicted anyone
during the pandemic and have reached
agreements with the majority of tenants
they added that pinedale is committed to
working with them on repayment plans
with the goal of keeping our residents
in their homes we have filed a limited
number of cases with the landlord tenant
board since march 1st
2020 relating to residents who were
overdue on rent
and did not respond to our outreach to
engage in dialogue
pinedale disputes zinet's claims about
the payments she has made
and say they will present evidence on
this matter in the hearing
in good faith we provided her with a
repayment proposal in november
she has chosen not to respond to that
offer or to enter into
negotiations zineth says that repayment
plan was
unreasonable it called for her to pay
nine hundred dollars a month for ten
months
on top of the fifteen hundred dollar
rent
a total of twenty four hundred dollars a
month that she
just doesn't have carly's landlord rainy
management claims it had good faith
discussions with her
and has been able to reach agreements
with most tenants they say eviction
is not their goal and rainey only filed
applications with the landlord and
tenant board for those tenants who
ignored our numerous requests
to communicate their individual
situation and did not make any payments
the group has since demanded rent
abatement for all pandemic-related
arrears for everyone
as a condition of further discussion
carly claims she
and her neighbors have never demanded
forgiveness of all debts
she says she started by asking for 25
percent
off her outstanding debt but was willing
to negotiate
please come discuss this with me that
was the simple ass the landlord's
reaction was to cash the check and send
a letter back saying
no deal and you still get taken to the
landlord tenant board so those people
who had already been repaying
were then taken to these eviction
hearings unlike many tenants who
represented themselves
carly's group was armed with documents
and a lawyer ready to defend them
so my hearing was adjourned because it
would have taken too long to hear it
they're set up to just happen as quickly
as possible so a tenant who comes in
with like an actual defense with pages
and pages of evidence you just get
adjourned
but many others without legal expertise
risk becoming homeless and during the
pandemic more and more people have taken
to living outside in tents
homelessness has always been killing
people but when you
have a pandemic at play it is so obvious
it has never been this stark dr andrew
buzari is the executive director of
social medicine at the university health
network
he is also the co-leader of toronto's
homelessness response
i think it's really important to
recognize that pre-pandemic we had a
housing crisis
tens of thousands of people across the
country who've been without stable
housing
close to ten thousand people in the city
of toronto
the big worry now is how many more
people will find themselves evicted
with nowhere to go we've already failed
tens of thousands of people in the
housing crisis to say that we're going
to have a whole new generation
of people move into chronic homelessness
i mean that's even more of a damning
failure amid another surge in cases of
the virus in january
and another shutdown ontario public
health officials called for more
protections
to help renters at risk of losing their
homes
it means income support and it means
protection from eviction
the province did order a temporary pause
on enforcement of eviction orders
but no further assistance for renters
meanwhile the eviction hearings continue
and the messaging from the premier has
not changed
stay at home
daisai jolly low fun you hear this
messaging
stay in your home how can i stay in my
home when i have an eviction order it
feels like we've been left behind by the
government by our landlord
they have dragged my neighbors and i to
the ltb in the middle of a global
pandemic
so they protest they strategize and if
necessary they physically block
sheriffs from evicting their neighbors
until landlords or the government steps
up with a long-term solution
these tenants say it's their last option
the stress of knowing that through no
fault of your own you've lost your job
you now won't be able to pay
and it just feels like you're just
sliding down a cliff or something
to save our home we need
rent relief we will help each other
we will make sure that everyone is safe
in their home
that is our commitment and we will fight
back
coming up on the new reality robots are
going to
complement people not replace them up
and down the grid they zip
this is the automated warehouse of the
future it takes
two years to build a facility like the
one i'm sitting in it's 100 million
dollar
investment we know we're on to something
special
there is a seismic shift taking place in
manufacturing
it's being called the fourth industrial
revolution harnessing the power of
robotics
artificial intelligence and machine
learning now
robots are tackling jobs we never
thought they could do in record time
how is canada positioned for this
transformation from investing
to training mike derlay examines if
we're prepared
for the big leap forward in a massive
new warehouse in the toronto area
grocery giant soby's has allowed the
robots to take over
up and down the grid they zip going on
to the next seemingly before they grab
the last
it's mesmerizing a symphonic ballet of
technology
and it's no small thing to say this is
the automated warehouse of the future
it takes two years to build a facility
like the one i'm sitting in it's 100
million dollar
investment from an outside perspective
it's easy to say soby's lucked out in
its timing
after all the pandemic forced millions
of canadians to stay home and work
remotely
pre-coveted online groceries with only a
one percent market penetration
wasn't exactly a raging success yet
sobes made a choice two years ago
to distinguish itself from its
competitors it needed something
big so it invested the 100 million
dollars in new technology
created by ocado a british company known
for automated warehouses
sobey's warehouse opened in the middle
of the pandemic in june
and in just eight months the big bet
appears to have paid off
sarah joyce is senior vice president of
e-commerce for sobes
we're seeing like a three-year pull
forward in what we expected of consumer
behavior so much more adoption much
quicker than we would have otherwise had
and as you probably have seen 300 plus
growth in online demand as a result
the automated warehouse uses aspects of
artificial intelligence robotics
and big data everything from the website
and mobile app to the facility's robots
and
finally the routing and logistics to get
orders where they're supposed to go
here humans do the grocery packing while
the robots sort and restock
while shopping can take a few hours out
of your day ocado's robots can help
fulfill a 50 item order
in five minutes if they move four meters
a second
you know they are just zipping past it
takes your breath away
it you you realize that there's nothing
quite that productive in the world
we're now well into the fourth
industrial revolution or
industry 4.0 which is all about
automation in artificial intelligence
so how is canada positioned for this
massive shift
[Music]
when sean gaffari became associate dean
of applied technology at humber college
in 2018
he saw the future of automation in
canada at a crossroads
the the stake is very very high here
because we are talking about the global
competition
and a lot of companies countries in the
world
they are ahead of us he looked at the
programs in canadian schools and saw a
problem
students were ill-prepared for this new
wave and canadian companies he believes
weren't going to invest in the future
if there were a few people qualified to
take them there we just need to
act fast we just need to
connect all of these thoughts together
to finally address
this skill gap which exists in the
industry
today there are 24 colleges in ontario
alone offering automation programs
along with mechatronics programs at four
universities
that growth has attracted top students
to the province including mauricio toygo
who says it's not hard to quantify the
opportunity
the brazilian expat says even during a
pandemic
graduates are finding jobs fast
you have not only to invest in in
developing
and implementing automation in our
factories but
we also need people that are capable of
working
uh with those machines that are capable
of developing them so the investment on
edu on the education side
and the industry side has to go um you
know at the same time
what's the risk if we don't get this
right the risk is that we're going to
lose our manufacturing capabilities and
we're going to have to
pretty much import everything that we
want to use and that's
not really good for for canada as a
whole
[Music]
the highly automated factory is still
far in the future for most manufacturers
digital advancements and ai have changed
jobs that were traditionally thought to
be impossible to be automated
but it's happening think driverless cars
automated buses and even
computer-generated social media
influencers
all this leads to the question can
humans in automation
coexist most of what's going to happen
is that robots are going to
complement people not replace them
outright but the end result is still not
so clear
university of waterloo economics
professor joel blitt decided to take a
long hard look at what canada needed to
do
post-pandemic automation he concluded
was both
inevitable and necessary to better
compete with the rest of the world
it's just common sense that taking days
to fulfill a curbside pickup order
can't compete with amazon's next day
delivery
if canadian companies take the plunge
into automation
blitz predicts a hollowing out of the
middle class
but the thing i'm most worried about is
potentially increasing inequality
because even after these you know the
market settles down
and people find new jobs it's not the
case that their new jobs are going to be
as good as their old jobs
history supports his argument as other
technological revolutions took hold
it led to a recalibration of the
workforce
in his book the technology trap carl
frey writes it took
decades for the lower class to recover
but if the same thing were to happen
today
canada with its vast social safety net
isn't a bad place to be
the places that seem to be doing better
are
the places that also have you know
reasonable welfare
systems like sweden so if you don't lose
your health care
with your job you have less to worry
about
from its perspective sobes refuses to
see automation
as a job killer will this result in
fewer jobs or have you had to hire
people
so it is absolutely the opposite it is a
job creation and i believe that
investments in innovation and
and in technology as i said they are not
without
people you need the people as well and
they are i think there's a perception
one way but the truth in our case is
we're creating 1500 jobs
it's a point automation consultant ben
angel agrees with but the point is he
sees it
is moot because canadian industry has
been slow to invest in new technology
and i would say 80 90 percent of all my
inquiries are
outside canada canadian companies they
know they have to
innovate they know they have to automate
but you can't fast track this
it's going to take a long time for
customers to really come up with the
proper budgets
because the automation's very expensive
when angel moved to canada
20 years ago the majority of robots in
the country could be found in the auto
sector
but even as canada modernized its
warehouses didn't
our factories are actually well
automated that happened
you know the assembly line that was
automated 20 25 years ago
so our canadian factories are well
automated
no issues with that but it's when that
product is made when it's moving
to the warehouse our warehouses are full
of forklifts
canadian companies love their forklifts
and that leads back to soby's and the
investment in the automated warehouse
robots
which has gone so well the company is
moving ahead with two more sites
in quebec and alberta and when they
eventually open a fourth
they'll be able to service 75 of the
canadian population
we know we're on to something special
and we plan to keep
rolling that out to as many canadians as
possible
next week on the new reality they
covered up the cause initially then they
said there was no
person-to-person contact that would
cause it to spread
and then they were sending out
flights from wuhan all over the world
it was scary to be honest with you i've
never seen
the city like that
to call it a ghost town is not an
exaggeration
the citizens from wuhan did nothing
wrong i don't believe
they wanted to spread this virus you
know across the country or across the
world
there are many many canadians who have
been friends of
china like i have who are
changing their views dramatically
[Music]
that is the new reality for this week
i'm donna friesen
thanks for joining us
you